most people never take the time to take
an inventory about their thoughts yet
our thoughts control our world we can't
live in fear we can't live in judgment
we can't be afraid of what the people
right now looking at me saying about me
someone's watching this they have thing
that something they want to change and
it's not it's not sticking then maybe
it's not it's the environment maybe you
could check about your habits but maybe
it's your beliefs and your values want
to be happy
build a life not just the business
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how to control your brain
and master your mind rule number one
take control of your thoughts with EDI
let do you ever think about what you
think about because if you did and if
you took control of that you could alter
the direction of your entire life most
people never take the time to take an
inventory about their thoughts yet our
thoughts control our world our thoughts
are like magnets they literally draw
towards us that's which we obsess about
and so most people never take the time
to analyze what they think about the
most successful people I know are the
most self-aware meaning they're aware of
what they do and they're also aware of
what they think they're aware of how
they're perceived average person you and
I have about seventy five thousand
thoughts a day rattling around in this
thing we call our brains in our mind
seventy-five thousand of them the crazy
thing is ninety one percent of those
thoughts are identical to the previous
day and are identical to the day before
that and the day before that and the day
before that and then we wonder why our
life seems to repeat itself over and
over again so really the difference in
our life if we have seventy five
thousand thoughts a day here's the crazy
thing 91 percent of them are exactly the
same the separation our life is in those
nine percent of their thoughts because
remember this these magnets are pretty
powerful that's why I'm always saying
that your obsessions become your
possessions because they do you draw
into your life exactly what it is you
think about it's a physical reality that
you attract to yourself what you think
about so the difference in our life is 9
percent of our thoughts that's why
people say all the time the difference
between winning and losing is so small
it's almost too scary to talk about and
really we have identified what it is
it's 9 percent of what we think about
alters the direction of our life so what
I'm here to tell you today is you've got
to hone in and/or get aware of what you
think about and then alter those 9
percent of the thoughts that are
variable on a daily basis to serve you
because we don't these thoughts become
like viruses they're viruses and our
minds what happens at a computer when it
gets a virus it slows down it becomes
sluggish it doesn't function in its
optimal level same thing with our
thinking if we don't get those 9 percent
of our thoughts to serve us our lives go
in a completely different direction so
remember this you don't see things in
your life as they are you see things in
life as you
and so the more you alter you the more
you begin to see things differently
which is amazing about this is we
control who we are by what we think
about think about this for a second
wherever you're sitting watching this
the chair that you're sitting in if
you're sitting in a chair if you're
driving in a car and you're listening to
this that seat you're in started in
someone's mind is a thought right every
detail of it the fabric the cushions the
way it's structured every single piece
of that started in someone's mind is a
thought and then became a reality by
putting out the pieces together step one
write down the thoughts that don't serve
you and eliminate them how do I
eliminate them by replacement you
eliminate them with replacement by
thinking a new thought it's as simple as
saying what thought would I need to have
that would serve me to get this goal or
dream or vision that I have and get that
thought write it down repeat it over and
over and over and over again because
there's a part of our brain called the
reticular activating system and it's the
filter that we see the entire world
through the reticular activating system
is the filter through which you see the
entire world it's powerful and so that's
why it filters out all the things in
your life that aren't important to you
so that you could be saying you don't
feel the blood rushing through your left
ear you don't you know you don't you're
not conscious of your breathing a
million stimulus would hit you if you
couldn't filter things out you'd go
crazy this allows you to only filter
into your consciousness what is most
important to you and what's most
important to you is what you think about
all the time and it creates a filter for
example that's why if something's
important to you the reticular
activating it to you through vision
sound touch you name it and so for
example you ever buy a new car you've
got a new you know blue Honda car
all of a sudden don't you see that car
everywhere it's on the third give me
three lanes over other side of the
freeway you see blue Honda's all of a
sudden everywhere they were already all
over the road why do you see them all of
a sudden you ever noticed that before
because that's become important to you
because it's it's part of your reticular
activating system now so what if you
could program your mind that the blue
Honda's of your life or your goals your
dreams and your visions and the way we
do that is repeated thinking looking at
our goals visualizing them seeing them
over and over again so let me give you a
couple tips to do that number one your
smartphone you check about four hundred
times a day
400 the most important thing you could
do is on your screen saver program the
thoughts that would serve you the goals
that would serve you that gives you 400
triggers a day every time you pick up
this phone you're looking at your blue
Honda's you're looking at what's most
important to you what happens is when
you put that down the RAS begins
unconsciously to help filter into your
existence the people the places the
conversations the things that will help
you materialize that space you've
created with the thought it fills it
with the furniture of your life the
furniture of the people places and
things so the second thing is to program
your phone with your goals and dreams
that's 400 triggers a day to begin to
alter those 9 percent of your thoughts
that's my challenge to you rule number 2
face the real you with David Goggins I
believe that most human beings are only
living at about 40% of their capability
so the mind has a governor like a car if
you're driving a car and the car has a
governor on it the car may say hundred
and thirty miles an hour but the
governor set 491 once that governor sets
in you get the 91 that car starts doing
this the car wants to go the car wants
to go but that factory said uh we're not
going past 91 we have a factory a nice
governor in our brain and it's a
survival mechanism it protects us from
pain and suffering the second we feel
that our mind says no no this isn't fun
we should back off we should sit down
find something more comfortable and
there's some about the mind the mind has
the tactical advantage over you at all
times at all times of your life the mind
has a tactical advantage over you why is
that it knows what you're afraid of it
knows your insecurities it knows your
deep dark lies and it starts to push you
away from that it pushes you in a
direction that is comfortable the mind
controls everything so what I realized
was that when I was growing up and I was
300 pounds and I got all fat and I got
all insecure I realized that my mind
kept taking me in this direction when
things get uncomfortable for me when I
was facing my insecurities I was facing
my fears my mind said oh no we have the
tactical advantage
we just get you separate you from this
feeling this feeling over your life's
all about feelings we want the happy
feeling we don't want that feeling of
this sucks
why am I here and you don't have any
choice oh you can't answer those
questions so you leave I started
realizing that if in that moment you can
answer those questions and you are now
in charge of your brain versus your
brain ruling you that's where all that
stuff comes from so the 40% rule is all
of that you get to 40% your brain says
we're done let's roll man this is trying
to get painful this is uncomfortable so
you sit down you have to figure out ways
and everybody's different that's how the
book kind of talks about like we all
have these things about you know five
steps to this and four steps to this
it's it's a lot more than that that's
all [ __ ] it's it's a practice that
you have to it's a habit so if you know
that 40 percent I'm still you know I'm
feeling pain and 40 percent feeling pain
that's where the 40 percent rule kicks
in now it starts okay I'm feeling pain
my mind's saying all this to me it's
saying get out of here run flee the
fight-or-flight kicks in okay we're
gonna we're not good enough and starts
telling you all these things you start
to believe it because the mind controls
all this is the time where you have to
gain control back of your mind it's okay
let me see if I can go 45 percent and
once you start giving yourself more and
more hope and start realizing okay the
mind starts to be okay what are you
doing we're supposed to be going right
and you're going left you start then
controlling your mind start finding more
in you know in yourself and it goes from
40% to a lot further than that but
that's the start of it though get to get
to the spot where your mind is saying
stop wherever that is you gotta get
there first and then that's when that
starts to work for you you got to
control yourself in that moment there a
lot of people could live with themselves
look in the mirror and say I'm okay with
being afraid I'm okay with going on
there's easy highway over here the easy
highway has all these signs and
directions how to get somewhere and you
have to first be uncomfortable with how
you feel about yourself
that voice that lavas like to run away
from we all have it we all have that
voice and say hey man you know you're
you're kind of whimpering out right now
you kind of be a little punk right now
but I would say okay that's okay it's
okay to tell you little white lies to
ourselves so you first have to face the
real you the real me is David Goggins
the real me is a guy looking at you
right now saying I don't want to be on
this show right now because I used to
stutter as a kid and I'm afraid of that
I'm afraid that here in a second I'm
gonna start stammering a stutter and the
whole world is gonna know that I have
all these issues but that's when I see
right now okay Goggins you got to go on
this show that's Goggins Goggins is
saying okay David Goggins you're a punk
life made you this way we can't live
like this we can't live in fear we can't
live in judgment we can't be afraid of
what the people right now are looking at
me saying about me we cannot be afraid
of that
that's Goggins Goggins saying all of you
who don't like me who don't want it in
that person then it comes in but you
have to be David Goggin to say man I'm
afraid of this I'm up here life made me
this way here I stutter I have these
issues with reading and writing and I'm
fat and I'm insecure you have to face
that in that dark room in that dark room
is who you are but in that dark room is
where you have to create another human
being that walks out of that dark room
to face who you are that's the only way
you're gonna get over all those things
you have to create someone else not like
you have two different personalities it
is you but you have to find strength in
that visualization of almost me cracking
out Goggins like almost like that
Superman cape like I'm coming out a
different person a person that doesn't
give a about anything who doesn't care
about being judged who knows I'm weak
who knows I'm afraid who says whatever
you think about me take it whatever I'm
here
that's guidance in the dark room you
face yourself you realize you want to be
better you realize you don't want to be
this weak insecure person in the world
who has all these problems that we all
have we all have so listen me is a great
platform to tell you who we want to be
now who we are
so that's where that darkroom is also if
you want to learn how to have more
confidence check of my to 54 confidence
series it's free the link is in the
description below the minute you begin
to get external in your life worrying
about what other people think about you
right you vote you've lost all control
you and it never fills you up everything
I didn't want to do is what got me to
where I'm at today and rule number three
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is change your beliefs with Jim
quick someone's watching this they have
everything that something they want to
change and it's not it's not sticking
then maybe it's not it's the environment
maybe you could check about your habits
but maybe it's your beliefs in your
values some people will not get
themselves to read every day because
they don't value reading every single
day right some people won't say the
behavior they won't change is you know
we did a podcast on how to remember
names I could teach them step-by-step on
how to remember the name of most people
that they meet yet they won't do it
because they don't value it or because
that's not important to them or they
don't believe that they can write just
like we talked about earlier saying your
brain is like a supercomputer and you
know your self talk to the programmer
run so if you tell yourself not go to
memory names you will not remember the
name the next person you meet because
you program your supercomputer not to
they don't have a belief that enables
that so when I say all behaviors belief
driven if you want to do this behavior
whatever it is journal whatever it is
then you need a belief that allows that
to happen because you mean that's the
program that allows it how do you get
that belief because you're gonna feel
like you're faking it all right that's
where most people stop right they think
okay I get it I hear what Jim is saying
that if I am able to shift my belief
then I can get a different behavior but
I don't believe it so now I'm just sort
of faking it how do you help people
overcome it right and so you so some
people approach it by they know there's
quote where they fake it so they make it
right and so my thing with belief is
like when I do trainings and groups or
are online my favorite way of changing a
belief is getting them to do something
they never thought they could do because
it opens up another possibility right so
so for example in 1954 Roger Bannister
he broke the four-minute mile right and
so which is amazing right throughout
human history nobody can run
less than four minutes now if you if you
look into it how he was able to do it is
he would visualize himself crossing the
finish line looking at the clock and it
says 359 because he knew that success is
an inside out process that first it had
to happen in here in order prepped and
out there right um dr. Wayne Dyer has
the famous phrase where it's not
oh I'll believe it when I see it it's
like I'll see it when I believe it
because it's the opposite right and so
yeah I always like modeling the outliers
where most people kind of just like kind
of dismiss them I was like well what's
what's going on there that loves this
person to get this kind of results right
and so with Roger Bannister he saw it in
here be able to produce it outside just
like any innovator or inventor or writer
any creator right but what was
interesting is after that would happen
nobody could do it from the beginning of
humanity
all of a sudden one person does it what
happens after that everybody yeah
everyone starts doing it and so that's
the thing now what happened was there
big change that year and you know
training methodology and nutrition or
know who's a change of belief right
because the belief back then was if you
ran a mile list of four minutes not only
would you die it was your heart would
explode in your chest and like think
about like that would and I'm a runner
right that would keep me not just
running that wouldn't give me for my
name for me that would keep me from
running period right right and so my
thing is like that was a change of a
reference I was just shook up a belief
so my goal with people and when it comes
to learnings get themselves to do
something they never thought they could
do and then it opens up another
possibility it literally opens up their
their nervous system for something what
else could be possible like when I grew
up I you know we didn't have any we we
had no money right I had no education
because I was a very learning challenge
I didn't know any anybody right so I
feel like it's not when people are
that's where they'll go though when they
when they hit them in as a gap stopgap
between where they are and where they
want to be they'll say oh I don't have
the money or and all the education
around the intelligence out of the
network or anything else like that and
you know what would you know as for all
incredible success you've had and the
value of you created for the world is
that it's not about resources right
because we know a lot of people who who
didn't have any resources that were able
to impact the world
it's about our internal resources what
I'm saying is
optimizing our environment optimizing
our behaviors or capabilities our
beliefs and our values and our identity
right that at the highest level our
identity because you can't just change
your belief or your values or your
behavior even if you don't believe
you're that kind of person and that's
why I kind of always go to the superhero
mythos because I want people that get to
claim that identity I call it this
superhero you that version of ourselves
and we're not waiting for Superman or
Batman or Wonder Woman it's like you are
Wonder Woman you are Batman you are
Superman it's just we we have to commit
ourselves to be able to unleashing now
I've got a special bonus clip with Garen
Jones on how to shift your mindset that
I think you're gonna enjoy but before
that it's time for the three-point
landing questions let's go from just
watching another video to taking action
here we go question number one
what's the belief change that you need
to make number two where do you need to
take control of your thoughts and number
three what does facing the real you look
like for you it's interesting when you
were in prison you started making
certain changes realizing I think you
obviously decided to learn friends she
started yeah using only your left hand
what is it about that mechanism of doing
the thing that's different doing the
opposite what was the result you got in
prison from that when I first got locked
up it was that I got busted for
smuggling 6.2 kilos of heroin I didn't
so basically I Drive this car from here
to this border you get this much money I
didn't look in the back because I didn't
want that on my conscience so I'm just
driving driving after the eighth time I
got caught and then they x-rayed the
vehicle and it was like boom I'm like
damn my life is I literally and I didn't
love my daughter was just born I'm like
ma'am my life is over
I had billboards like billboards in
Times Square and when you're remodeling
modeling stuff so billboards commercials
out I just interviewed with like MTV
like and in that moment I'm like I don't
even know what's about to happen but
when they open up those Congo drums and
they pulled out those little yellow
and I like my life is I don't even know
what they are but my life is over they
put me in prison I wrote 200 people
seven people wrote me back so just
imagine the mindset of your friends and
it wasn't too many people there my
daughter's mother was there my mom was
there my boy Troy my brother a couple of
other people and I was like my life is
over and I'm literally looking at the
clock when I got sentenced they
sentenced me till 2014 back in 2003 and
I'm like it's over like every dream I've
ever had
singing modeling acting like any kind of
inspiration
over my daughter won't even know me and
I remember my consulate it came in and
they're like we think you might like
this book because by that time I was
just reading anything that would keep my
mind off of being in there I just
started reading reading reading reading
I read a bunch of Agatha Christie books
cuz they was just like imagination and
all this kind of stuff and I just
started reading I read the Bible
cover-to-cover eight times I read the
Quran cover-to-cover eight I was like
they saying the same thing it was like
it was very fascinating I just kept
reading and reading I didn't know that
what was filling my brain was causing an
energy inside I had none of the I'll
because I wasn't aware but then my my
consulate there's like we think you
might like this book power of positive
thinking all I know is I'm reading this
book I'm reminded of everything that I
loved as a child I start doing it it
makes me happy like super happy I'm
running doing all this other stuff
officer and everybody starts there was
less fights less stabbings less drug
deals and I didn't know
that my own personal desire and joy was
causing that to happen I was just in it
doing what I loved to do and then we
were allowed to watch and this was the
shift we were allowed to watch TV once a
month Shawshank Redemption came on and
auntie Robin said they can take
everything away from me they can't take
away my mind as long as I'm doing
everything I'm I love and I'm free
if you want to learn how Tony Robbins
trains his mind and body check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there if you want in
suffering you have to make the most
important decision your life which says
I want to live in a beautiful state
every day no matter what